les deux hommes ne se font pas confiance
et même lors de la poignée de main un
léger malaise
rencontre de 90 minutes entre le
ministre des affaires étrangères un tony
blinken et son homologue russe sergueï
lavrov à la question est-ce qu'une
invasion est possible
[Musique]
à moins que les états unis n'avaient
touly avec l'ukraine je ne crois pas
répond t-il
sur le terrain la tension est grande
plus de cent mille soldats russes sont
toujours postés à la frontière
ukrainienne
il ya également beaucoup de mouvements
des forces russes au bélarus au nord de
l'ukraine et en crimée dans le sud des
navires militaires russes serait
également en route bref une attaque
serait imminente selon la maison blanche
les etats-unis ne veulent pas revivre le
même scénario qu'en 2014 où la russie a
annexé la crimée
nous nous engageons à poursuivre la voie
diplomatique et régler nos différends
dit il mais si cela s'avère impossible
et que la russie poursuit son agression
contre l'ukraine la riposte sera sévère
et rapide
swift
moscou maintient la même demande un nom
élargissement de l'otan à ses portes et
surtout réclame que l'ukraine ne fasse
pas partie de l'organisation
nous attendons des réponses concrètes et
le respect des obligations qui ont été
adoptées au sein de l'organisation pour
la sécurité et la coopération
moscou veut des garanties par écrit des
américains
nous répondront par écrit aux
inquiétudes soulevées par la russie
dit-il mais pas question d'empêcher
l'ukraine de faire partie de l'otan vers
19 h à l'espace terre
à kiev la population s'attend à tout et
à l'impression que l'avenir de l'ukraine
se négocie à genève entre les états unis
et la russie
il négocie entre didier l'ukraine n'est
qu'une monnaie des changes
nous avons plus de pouvoir et
d'influencé dit celui-ci est n'ya même
pas assez de compagnies américaines en
ukraine pour qu'ils s'en soucie
en attendant la grande bretagne a déjà
envoyé des missiles antichars à
l'ukraine et les américains viennent de
donner le feu vert aux états baltes pour
envoyer des missiles antiaériens javelas
estime gueule à l'ukraine
les deux hommes se sont entendus pour
poursuivre les pourparlers la semaine
prochaine et il n'est pas exclu que le
président américain s'entretiennent avec
vladimir poutine
et pour joe biden c'est un autre test
sur sa politique étrangère avant les
élections de mi mandat surtout après la
débâcle en afghanistan lors des retraits
des troupes américaines cette fois
washington ne veut montrer aucun signe
de faiblesse ici elle est bonne les gars
guise radio-canada washington